have you noticed that almost all big
court rulings against Tech monopolies
and for Tech regulation comes from the
EU within just the last 6 years European
countries have taken action against
Google seven times Apple two times
Facebook three times Microsoft one time
and Amazon one time these usually
consist of billions of dollars worth of
fines lawsuits regarding
anti-competitive practices
investigations into Power abuse and of
course new standards for apple and those
are just the most notable cases from the
you for perspective the biggest lawsuit
that American authorities have brought
against big Tech in recent times is
suing to block Microsoft from acquiring
activation blizzard and in the end this
didn't really do anything anyway given
that Microsoft ended up closing on the
deal later the same year as such the EU
has often been described by the press as
the last regulatory body that's truly
fighting to keep big Tech in check but
while their efforts have painted them as
somewhat of a valiant hero this
Relentless Pursuit has not been with
without consequences for example Europe
has no big tech companies of their own
in fact the only two European tech
companies that even make the Fortune 100
are asml and sap in contrast seven of
the top 10 largest companies in the
world are American big tech companies at
this point you can even argue that
birkar haway itself is just a tech
holding company given that almost half
of their portfolio is just Apple stock
Europe is also getting the short end of
the stick when it comes to Big tech
companies ation with big tech companies
regularly paying Europeans 25 50% less
for the exact same jobs yet despite all
of this the EU has continued their Noble
pursuit of maintaining free markets and
minimizing monopolization just last
month for example the EU started
investigating Elon musk's X but why does
the EU truly just care that much about
their people and the corporate landscape
or is there some more ulterior motives
at play well here's the real reason why
the EU keeps Prosecuting big
Tech taking a more macro perspective
it's likely that Europe's moves against
big Tech are less of an offensive move
and more of a defensive move you see
Europe has been getting left behind
within the tech industry since really
the 1960s and 1970s the era in which
Silicon Valley was born we saw the rise
of gen One tech companies like Fairchild
semi conductor Intel AMD IBM Microsoft
and Apple this was largely thanks to the
high-risk highw mentality of Americans
across the board in terms of company
leadership you had a bunch of
20-year-olds with no experience dropping
out of college and betting it all on a
company in terms of venture funding
Silicon Valley almost created a sort of
self-sustaining funding model the
winners of each decade would go on to
become billionaires and establish their
own VCS and incubators that supported a
whole new generation of St startups and
in terms of Regulation all of the laws
were set up to reward winners as much as
possible while also subsidizing losers
as much as possible this meant lower
taxes for companies less regulation
government grants tax credit political
favors and so on on the flips side if
your Venture didn't work out you still
enjoyed solid bankruptcy protections the
ability to try again and sometimes even
government bailouts this sort of
landscape was simply pushed into
overdrive when President Ronald Reagan
came into power and implement Ed his
controversial Reaganomics he cut the
personal income tax from 70% down to 28%
the corporate tax from 45% down to 35%
and he would be dubbed the great
deregulates moves were actually better
for America over the longterm or not are
highly debated but one thing is for sure
these moves basically pave the road for
trillion dollar Giants and mega
billionaires at the same time Europe was
taking a far more conservative approach
they stuck with their high taxes focused
on social welfare maintained tight
regulations and they were largely risk
averse in fact to this day eight out of
the top 10 countries with the highest
personal income tax rates are European
countries nine out of the top 10
countries with the highest sales tax
rates are also European countries and
Social Security tax can be as high as 65
to 68% in Europe what all of this means
is that it's not uncommon for even
middleclass Europeans to pay over half
of their income to various taxes and if
you're a wealthy European you could be
paying as much as 70 to 80% of your
income to various taxes for contrast 40%
of us households don't pay any federal
income tax whatsoever and the highest
income earners often get away with the
lowest tax rates again whether this is
healthy or not is highly contested but
one thing that's for sure is that it's
far better to be a rich person in
America than a rich person in Europe and
as such taking stupid high risks to
become stupid rich is far more appealing
to Americans in Europe it simply makes
far more sense to reduce risk with
increasing net worth as more and more of
your income will be handed over to the
government anyway for the longest time
this difference in mindset didn't really
incite an economic difference the
American tech industry was just a niche
portion of the economy while the real
heavy weights were Pharmaceuticals Banks
retail Giants Industrials and energy
sectors in which Europe had a bunch of
their own heavy weights but all of this
changed with the turn of the century
after which Tech became the dominant
player since then Europe has been
falling behind across the board whether
it be return on invested Capital Growth
capital investment or R&D and all of
these shortfalls are almost
single-handedly due to just Tech in fact
McKenzie estimates that over 90% of the
shortfall in return on invested Capital
over 60% of the shortfall in growth over
80% of the shortfall in investment and
over 70% of the shortfall in R&D are due
to Europe's Tech inferiority to make
things even worse big Tech and America
have been playing Europe for fools for
[Music]
decades while Europe has been quite
successful at taxing their own citizens
and companies the same cannot be said
about American companies who have some
insanely sophisticated ways to avoid
taxes take Apple for example they like
to hold a vast majority of their
intellectual property in countries with
extremely favorable tax laws like
Ireland this way they can minimize their
International tax load by funing the
vast majority of their profits through
these tax Havens last year for example
Apple made just over $110 billion out of
which 70 billion dollars went through
Ireland it's the same thing with
Microsoft Google meta and any other big
tech company that you can think of
schemes like these are why Amazon was
able to get 44 billion worth of sales
from Europe without paying a dime in
corporate tax now to be fair big de
companies leverage these same strategies
to avoid American taxes as well usually
at even larger scales but it's a
completely different Dynamic for
starters these companies employ millions
of Americans who earn multi6 figures who
end up paying a crap ton in income tax
sales tax property tax Social Security
tax and so on even with America's more
favorable tax laws but let's even put
tax revenue aside even if big tech
companies paid identical taxes to
America and Europe the two are not even
comparable it's almost like comparing
Jeff Bezos to the average American
before Jeff retired he was only earning
a modest
$81,400 on paper an amount that's quite
comparable to the average American now
of course you're probably saying that
Jeff was earning tens of billions
through stock appreciation and you're
completely right so let's say Jeff
wasn't allowed to sell any of his $100
billion Amazon Fortune similar to how
America isn't able to cash in on the
profits earned by big Tech Jeff would
still not even be close to being
comparable to the average American
despite only earning 80k this is because
Jeff would still have leadership over a
trillion dollar company influence over a
million employees control over a third
of the global Cloud market and sales of
over $500 billion just to name a few
perks also he could borrow against his
Amazon Fortune to fund an insane
lifestyle without selling a scent of
Amazon stock it's the same case with
America as a whole just at a much larger
scale sure they may not make much tax
revenue from Big Tech but they're still
the Home Country to tech companies worth
tens of trillions of dollars with a
dominant control over the entire globe's
Tech and internet the amount of raw
power influence wealth dominance and
control that America gets from Big Tech
on a macroeconomic and political scale
is incomprehensible China saw that this
is where things were heading back in the
1990s and that's why they banned most
American Tech Giants and created their
own Tech Giants Europe on the other hand
largely ignored this Strand and did
virtually nothing to cultivate their own
Tech Hub 20 years later this has left
Europe in a much less desirable position
of Simply being a consumer of tech as
opposed to being an owner of tech and if
we look back at history the key to power
and wealth has always been control over
Capital throughout the entirety of human
history from the ancient Kings who owned
entire regions of land to the 18th
century land owners who forged fortunes
using slave labor to the guilded age
industrialists who controlled every
sector known to mankind the key was
always capital for the past 1,000 years
Europe has been the leader of global
Capital but over the past few decades
they have effectively dropped the ball
in regards to Tech capital and now
they're trying to claw back as much Tech
Capital as possible with the help of
regulatory control bringing us to the
modernday
Europe
with all of this extra context it
becomes apparent that all of the eu's
lawsuits regulations and fines are less
of a heroic effort to keep big Tech in
check and save the world or something
and more of a last Stitch effort to save
themselves in the new Global Order Bill
Gates has long speculated that Europe is
on its way to becoming an open air
museum for Americans and East Asians and
honestly this reality is looking more
and more likely by the day they've been
falling behind for half a century
they've transitioned from being owners
of capital to Consumers and now they're
using their last political resources to
Simply delay the inevitable because
let's be honest that's all that's
happening I mean do you really think
Apple has any less Global power just
because they had to switch to USBC
earlier than they wanted to or that
Google or Facebook really care about the
multi billion Euro fines that cost a few
weeks worth of profit of course not this
is just the cost of of doing business
and maintaining international relations
Also regarding taxes Europe has been
trying to get big Tech to pay more taxes
through new regulation and some of these
efforts have been successful at
generating more tax revenue but there's
just one problem it's not the big tech
companies that are paying these taxes
it's the Europeans big tech companies
have more than enough pricing power to
pass on these taxes directly to European
consumers that's why iPhones cost
hundreds of dollars more in Europe so
the sad reality is that Europe's Antics
against the big Tech is not only not
hurting or even slowing down these
Giants but often times their policies
are backfiring and ending up costing
Europeans now none of this is to say
that Europe is going to end up as the
third world or something but a fate like
Japan seems increasingly likely a more
or less stagnant region that's simply
cashing in on the Glory Days of their
past do you see a different outcome for
Europe comment that down below also if
you'd like to learn more about Europe's
rapidly crumbling Tech salaries check
out this video but until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next
one